the legalization of recreational
marijuana in almost a dozen states shows
how our attitude towards the drug is
changing something else has changed the
drug itself newly developed strains of
marijuana are far stronger than what
people were smoking in the past Carter
Evans takes a look at what can happen
when people encounter this very potent
pot how long is your recovery gonna take
a lifetime 20 year-old Colton says he
got hooked on marijuana in high school
when it became legal in Colorado five
years ago but the cheers back then have
turned into unintended consequences for
Colton and others much younger typically
young children around the age of 2
mostly getting into caregivers whether
it's parents grandparents babysitter's
marijuana products often edible products
dr. Sam Wong's findings from Colorado's
children's hospital are included in a
new nationwide study showing a 27%
increase in children and teenagers
getting emergency treatment for
marijuana toxicity 70% from states with
legalize marijuana severe circumstances
it can affect how they're breathing and
make them comatose and be put on a
ventilator an exponential increase in
marijuana psychoactive ingredient THC
tetrahydrocannabinol is at the center of
the crisis THC levels jump from 3.7
percent to more than 20% and some
cannabis concentrates contain close to
100% once it was legalized it was so
easy to get it at the highest grade in
the in the strongest form straight from
the dispensary Colton's dad believes
high levels of THC fueled his son's
addiction this nuclear strength
chemically engineered rocket science PhD
is coming in and making this stuff
stronger than any strains of wheat
anyone has ever known is there anything
the industry can do to regulate the
levels of THC in these products
I mean what's important about potency is
that the consumer knows what they're
buying and what they're consuming and
that is through consistent testing
standards and labeling standards on
these products and that only exists
under the Reg
related markets states that legalized
marijuana have generated almost three
billion dollars in tax revenue since
2014 when Colorado first started sales
the state was highly focused on how much
tax revenue who could generate from
marijuana sales
nobody really spent a lot of time
thinking about well how was this going
to impact some of the younger community
the impact on his son became clear when
Colton was failing in college couldn't
quit cannabis and then asked to go to
rehab how hard was it to go ask for help
that's the hardest thing to do I mean
the worst part of it is that until you
do that it doesn't get better it only
gets worse for CBS this morning Saturday
Carter Evans Los Angeles I haven't
thought about that the idea that that
more potent strain maybe more addictive
really hits home there when Carter s in
how long will your recovery take a
lifetime right and it's something for
states to consider as they look to
legalize recreational marijuana to take
this into account some of these
unintended consequences